I had like a really really tough time
over the last year me and my
ex-girlfriend we split up I basically
had to move back in my mum and dad and
just kind of went into what I did only
can describe as like [__] and anxiety
this is when my mum sent me one of your
YouTube videos I've got the treasure map
now and I've drawn a line exactly where
I need to go you sold your business and
you basically had nothing living with
your parents and you invested everything
and now you're private how much are you
making now in your property business uh
just over 15K a month Monday morning I
got the keys to one deal and then Monday
afternoon I got keys to another deal and
then on the Friday of that same week I
got the keys to another day after my
service accommodation business manages
six a service accommodation unit spend
1200 to the landlord and then how much
turnover is that one property bringing
you in that's turning over just a little
bit more than three thousand pounds a
month in a minute
[Music]
Adam thanks for coming to my house well
thank you very much for having me so
your background sports sports therapy
yeah yes or a physiotherapist I got a
degree in that going to University and
stuff like that and
um did that for about five years of
super dyslexic growing up as well so
actually getting to that point was
really tough for me English GCSE took me
five times five attempts to actually get
it to even go to university and when I
got to University my tutor went to me
Adam just try and pass the degree don't
really aim too high because we know what
you dyslexia and stuff in the exams we
might not be able to get you that grid
that you want and kind of told them to
shove it and got a two one anyway so
yeah so don't aim high just just just
just just survive don't survive yeah
yeah yeah and now you're thriving how
much are you making now in your property
business uh just over 15K a month at the
minute but it is growing very big like I
say in the last eight weeks is when I've
really just started making profit and it
it's just flying it's really funny crazy
so I mean I really want to win this
interview I want to find out you know
obviously a bit of backstory about you
and where how you started you started
with very little money yeah yeah so um
well
go coming into property like I knew that
property is something I've always wanted
to do I've always seen myself especially
as a physio is like I am the asset
people pay for my time and I've always
seen a seal into that and I haven't seen
like the growth that you can see like in
business and in scaling and things like
that and then I've seen property is like
well I'm taking myself away from that
and now I'm no longer the asset the
asset is the property yes so you can
scale that you can have one you can have
two you can have six you can have twelve
ten twenty don't matter yes like and
each time each one of them's making you
money so like you say you're putting
your money to work so this is something
that I've wanted to explore but I've
never really like known too much about
so hence why I wanted to to learn more
about it really so where were you last
year then what was going on a year ago
or so ago so I had like a really really
tough time over the last year it's been
honest like mentally with my mental
health and things like that so me and my
ex-girlfriend
um we split up in April we was renting a
house together I was pretty sure that
she was the one kind of thing we had a
pet and everything together and then we
end up splitting up in April loads of
different stuff like transpired and
things like that and I basically had to
move back in with mum and dad lost the
house lost my pet and just kind of went
into a bit of a dark place with like
what I did Anakin describe as like
crippled anxiety like not being able to
do anything just tightness in my chest
all the time and things like that and
I just didn't really know what I was
doing at this point I'm trying to run a
health and well-being business as well
just like the business is all about
mental health and understanding these
kind of things I just felt like a bit of
an imposter really because I couldn't
even manage my own mental health at the
time yeah
um and that led me to just going down a
bit of a path of like leaving that
business as well and I sold my shares in
that business and just felt like
completely lost like I've taken a
massive step back in my life I've moved
back in my mum and dad I've lost
what I thought was going to be my
partner for the rest of my life and then
this is when my mum sent me one of your
hot YouTube videos about property and
she knew that I'd always wanted to do
more property the fact that we'd I'd
flip to house when my grandma passed
away a few years ago as well I'd
renovated that house and done it to a
really nice standard so we ended up
making about 20 25 000 pounds profit on
that in the time at the time that we did
it and that just opened my eyes to the
potential in in this space really so you
knew that like property was the one yeah
yeah but you needed a bit of a plan and
how do I do it yeah how much money did
you have at the time when you live with
your parents so when I saw my business I
sold my business for just over ten
thousand pounds so I had like a little
bit of a cushion yeah really but I'm a
massive believer in investing yourself
as you save them that said many times
that you pay a few mistakes you pay for
your education so
um it's something that I really knew I
wanted to invest in I wanted to make
sure that I was putting the money into
my self because at the end of the day I
number one best investment that you're
going to make is in yourself at the end
of the day I think so yeah and like you
say about properties being a massive
asset because you can have lots and lots
lots of love which is great but still if
you've got 10 grand 20 grand it's not
going to go that far in the property
industry you might buy one house if
you're lucky and it's going to be some
really far north crappy house that might
make 100 a month but if you invest a few
grand in yourself
your network your education your mind
your contacts your team your investor
list
suddenly yeah everything can change what
was your first um program that you came
to it's the first program was the deal
selling the deal selling program so I
came to the crash course
um in the end of June with my mom my mum
and my brother actually came to that
together and I remember just being blown
away by just your energy but the the
teaching methods of how high energy
everything is and then just
understanding that I remember leaving
that day and being like I've got I've
got a Clear Vision now it's like every
other business or every other Venture
I've done in the past I've been like
this is cool now but I don't see the
longevity in it I don't see how it's
going to get me to where I want to be I
remember leaving that crash course on
that Discovery day and just been like
this this is it like I know that this is
going to be the thing I know this is
going to work I know where I'm going to
be each step along the way it might move
a little bit but that pathway is kind of
like it's like I've got the treasure map
now and I've drawn a line exactly where
I need to go no it was like it was such
an eye-opening moment and I remember
leaving and talking to my mum about it
and stuff and I was like do not tell Dad
how much I've just invested in going
into going into these courses because my
dad wouldn't have been happy about that
so how much did you invest so this one
was two thousand pounds at this point in
total how much of it could you this is
the first one your dad will know yeah
do you think my dad thinks I've done
four thousand pounds how much is
actually twelve thousand pounds twelve
thousand there we go dad there we go Dad
12.
wow and and what do you think your dad
would think when he finds out I think
now when he looks back like I I love my
dad to bits my mum and dad are the most
supportive people I'm very very grateful
I'm very lucky for that they've
supported me throughout this whole
process obviously letting me move back
in after the breakup in everything as
well and so it's been amazing but I
think you'll be pretty shocked if
probably if you're sipping his coffee
right now it might spit out how did you
justify I mean you sold your business
and you basically had nothing living
with your parents and you invested
everything
yeah into your education how did you
justify that I believe in myself I think
that like I say I've done so much in
terms of
um like my my old business used to do
like wealth health and well-being
training and I used to teach people
about the importance of investing in
yourself around your mindset and your
mental health and your exercise and your
body and your health and I knew that
admit I'm a hypocrite if I don't believe
in that myself so I've always wanted to
invest in myself I've always known that
the reach won't teach one kind of
mentality of reach up and get help from
somebody else and then reach down and
help other people and teach other people
Inspire others as well amazing bro and
another thing is why a lot of people say
to me I got like 10 grand 20 grand and
the realistic thing that they need to do
is they need to raise Finance yeah right
that I'm sure you're you've joint
ventured and raised Finance for your
deals you have to raise Finance you have
to join Venture you have to partner with
people but how can you expect someone to
invest in you
oh I've got 100 grand for this deal can
you invest in my deal if you can't even
invest in you if you won't investing
because you're like oh no I won't invest
in me then then how will anybody else
yeah that's it and it's what I think
it's one thing that it's really
important to put yourself out there in
this sense and like show people what
you're really about and talk talk about
things that you really believe in
because you will connect with people and
you need to connect with people
personally before you do business
especially on the level where you're
talking about raising Finance together
in your like you're using someone else's
money in a deal they need to have a real
belief in a friendship with you I
believe before they just go oh yeah
here's 50 Grand kind of thing like that
100 so what happened is he joined the
academy you've now got access to all the
mentoring training what happened yeah so
I went heavy into the the deal selling
side of things first and kind of went
into building up my investor list really
trying to hit social media hard which
I've had a lot of experience with in the
past and then I partnered with a guy who
actually met at one of the courses
called Dan Jonesy's my business partner
throughout everything now and he like
it's amazing the network of people that
you meet when you come to your courses
because me and him just clicked we got
like a house on fire and now everything
that we do we we split 50 50 with our
service accommodations our uh still
selling stuff as well and going into our
project management and um be our
business as well that we're currently
currently looking at building it's just
it's amazing because I've got that
background experience of the marketing
the social media the things like that
and running a business where he's a
Tradesman he fits kitchens for a living
so he's got that that plug in the Gap
there so I met him through the training
and then
um been able to utilize the the
mentoring calls and things like that
because I didn't actually get a deal for
the first three months which I didn't
actually get a deal when you first
started in property but it's like a lot
of other people that joined on the
academy at my time are on the Mastermind
every single week and you're surrounded
by people that are winning the
constantly getting deals and things like
that and it's amazing and it just lit
this fire in my belly or like I had to
get get something I had to get something
of the line so I got one deal uh on a
Monday
Monday morning I got the keys to one
deal and then Monday afternoon I got
keys to another deal and then on the
Friday of that same week I got the keys
to another deal so it's like all this
work over the three months and just
compounding to me getting three rent
service accommodations in one week how
did that happen how did it suddenly all
come together the sheer amount of nose
but using no as a step forward to a yes
rather than something that's gonna
that's gonna pull you back so you were
ringing up landlords and you were
finding on the internet Gumtree Facebook
Marketplace
agents you're ringing these guys up and
and you're pitching
to basically write the property and do a
rent to rent yeah yeah well so like I'd
get I'd get leads I'd get viewings and
stuff and then I'd lose one viewing on
the fact that I'd mention like Airbnb
and they didn't like it it's like a
trigger word then I'd mention company
let another one and that were a trigger
word that they didn't like and I'd say
something that someone else didn't like
and it's
it's all about like it's like it's split
testing you've got to like learn about
what
what works and what doesn't so yeah I
built up a script in my mind which
um okay well that doesn't work so I'm
going to change that a little bit okay
well I've got past this bit now but that
bit don't work so I'm going to change
just a little bit and eventually you get
to the point of where
now everything works and then all of a
sudden everything works
it works on all the deals so that's
three properties in a week that
that kind of all came together and I
remember as well coming to one of your
properties because we we spend quite a
lot of time on trying and practicing the
scripts yeah yeah like what do you say
when you call landlords what if they say
this what do you say like as you say
it's like yeah crafting that because
that's basically sales isn't it yeah
yeah it's really honing your sales
skills in and I remember coming out and
you had the most difficult situation
what happened yeah this is crazy so I
messaged a guy on the upper and and it
was open to the idea of it it called me
straight away and I kind of sold him on
the idea to get a viewing and then I
went around to the viewing and
um it was crazy because the guy who was
the landlord was 93 years old which is
crazy in itself and then
um yeah and he was like say he was open
to the concept but it was like just in
case
um I pass away at any point I need to
make sure that my my granddaughter
understands the concept of what's going
on as well so what I want you to do when
you come to the viewing is I want you to
pitch the idea to her as well
and her partner yeah and then her
partner
[Laughter]
like right go ahead so you are having to
basically present yeah yeah and Pitch
the concepts
yeah yeah to to him him
firing all these questions at you which
we've been training on track yeah and
all the questions that they said like is
it going to be on Airbnb yeah yeah let's
let's let the guys listening to the
interview here some of the objections
that come up all the time because I want
to make this as valuable as possible
yeah what you should say so what were
you gonna say man is it on Airbnb you're
gonna put on Airbnb so we use the
property short-term stage yes but we try
to drive a lot of bookings direct
through uh through our direct booking
website but in the times where we do
have low periods then we do use online
travel agencies like Airbnb to Market
our properties and potentially build up
future leads with other potential
businesses in the future do you have any
any references or anything could you you
know to to give me uh yeah of course I
can I can pass you some I can pass you
across some references from other
landlords that we've worked with in the
past but I'm also um my business is also
a sister business of a business called
Samuel Leeds limited who done a lot of
mentoring and training with me so um if
there is any other issues I'm sure I can
patch you up the details along to them
and they can give you a little bit more
information about the business when you
say company let though
um who's going to be living in the
property exactly Yeah so basically how
it works is that we rather than it being
a normal tenancy agreement so with a
normal tendency contract an AST contract
what you actually have is the tenant
that you have has a lot of Rights so
there's a lot of issues there with if
they don't pay the rent and things like
that then you're going to have problems
removing them because of the tenants
rights with a company like this is like
a lease agreement so if you imagine like
the big hotels like the Premier Inns or
travel lodges what they do is they lease
the building that they're in they don't
own that building but they let it out on
a short night by Night basis we're
basically doing that but on a much
smaller scale so I'm a company that's
leasing the property off you so my
company is the tenant and then what I'll
basically do is be using your property
on a shorter term basis to actually let
it out to contractors to healthcare
professionals and different people that
need short-term stays in here area is
this legal though isn't subletting
illegal yes the subletting would be
illegal if I was a standard tenant so if
it wasn't an AST contract but like I say
this is a similar contract to what the
big hotels and things like that use so
we're allowed to do the short-term stays
what happens if you don't pay the rent
now that's the beautiful thing of it
because if I was an AST and understand a
tenant the issue would be that you
wouldn't be able to remove me from the
property but it tends to be within the
the contents of our agreement if the
payment isn't made within seven days you
can actually remove it and you can put
another tenant into there straight away
so it's actually a lot more beneficial
for you and yourself as well I'm sold
man see that's the thing that's the
power of knowing how to answer questions
and there's a whole bunch I think
there's like probably under 30 40
different questions I could ask you yeah
yeah exactly you need to know how to
answer the questions that's that is 100
it and again it goes back to sales and
it goes back to like your story but
that's what took me three months to
learn it took me three months of getting
nerves go interviewings and seeing
people like over and over again yeah
saying them key trigger words like I
personally don't like saying like you're
saying when I did that then I'd never
say company let I say my company will be
the tenant I think again company letter
is becoming a little bit of a trigger
term yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I think
that it's like again but that's just
come from the test how many properties
do you have I managed six at the minute
you've got six rentals six trans yeah
yeah how much are you making on the rent
to rent so three of them are ones that
have so an investors put the money in so
it's almost a little bit like a it's a
sauce a sauce image like a joint venture
at the same time so an investor sourced
three of them I've project managed the
staging and the Furnishing and things
like that and then I actually managed
the asset inside of it now so my service
accommodation business manages six a
service accommodation units so I've
given from a term of a sourcing point of
view it's a complete the hands-off
investment okay help me out so who found
the property me who put the money in the
investor so you're taking some of the
profits the investors taking some of the
profit yeah so I'm taking a management
fee but it's their property basically
okay so they've they've paid me a source
in fee for finding it it's their
property
three thousand pounds so you got three
grand
plus you're making a monthly amount from
it as well what about the other three
they're the three ones that I've I've
asked myself and who's aren't they yours
there's mine and my business partner
Dungey and how much do they make each
one of them is between a thousand and
fifteen hundred and who are staying in
your properties are you not worried that
you're gonna like for instance in the
winter you're not worried about dry
seasons I'm not at all because I believe
in building a brand around it so even
though my business my business furnished
accommodation which is my essay
management company I don't Market it
I'll put it out there as an essay
management company it is the hub for
contractor stairs around the north of
England so I Market that to contractors
to people to like relocaters to nhf
Locum stuff and things like that yeah I
Market it to them to stay for longer
periods around so you're not just
sticking on Airbnb you're genuinely
targeting and marketing to people
contractors that are looking for
short-term accommodation yeah I'm career
hundred pound a month per property doing
that because when you put it on Airbnb
and things like that exactly like what I
was saying before like we do use them
platforms to fill the gaps and to fill
the time that where we don't get direct
bookings but through that when we're
trying to get direct bookings then we
remove the fees at Airbnb booking.com
take so it allows us to then actually
maximize on the profits that we're
getting what was the first property that
you took on yourself and where was it
that was in Liverpool it was a
two-bedroom duplex apartment right you
buying uh we paid 1200 on that do you
find 1200 to the landlord yeah and then
how much turnover is that one property
bringing you in that's turning over just
a little bit more than three thousand
pounds a month at the minute sure so
after bills and everything that's
profiting around over the three months
it's been live but it's been around a
thousand pounds 700 to a thousand pounds
damn bro that's nice it's nice that
wasn't you yeah so is it hard business
is it tough nut to crack you've got to
have that dedication this is where the
academy and the mentoring and
surrounding yourself with the right
people really helped me because the the
issue is when you get a no and you're
not used to getting nerves it's
demotivating like I was saying before
about it took me five attempts to get my
English GCSE I'm used to being told no
so it's like a lot of the time when
people have said go left I've gone right
so I had that kind of
um I had that kind of like drive to move
past it but then it is demotivating when
you call in 10 agents or 10 landlords a
day and you and and you get no no no no
no no it's like
why do people say no do they not
understand the concept it's a brilliant
service rent to rent assuming it's done
properly by a company that's got
references that can afford to do it
that's you know got the right training
it's a brilliant service I mean my
properties a lot of my houses I've
passed on to people on winter rents yeah
because it's it's passive yeah hassle
free yeah and you're normally offering
the rent that they want I know
for that apartment I'll give you a brand
a month and I'll give it you on a
company let which means that I've got no
rights if I don't pay you can take my
house away yeah and I'm going to be
making sure it's cleaned to the point
whereby they won't even be hair in the
bed
what the heck is wrong with people say
no don't do company let's
I don't know it's just it must just
purely be the fact that they don't
understand I think it's all the bum
buckets that are trying to do rent to
rent they're doing it wrong yeah the
Cowboys
investigation oh no Manchester's too far
I live in Leeds I don't want to spend a
pound on the course
but I'll bring up landlords and just
mess up everything and then and then or
they'll take on a contract and not be
able to pay the rent they don't know how
to list it on booking.com yeah well they
don't know how to systemize it because
you've got to have procedures and
cleaners and key safe boxes and things
right yeah it's a business yeah that's
it I had someone message me on Instagram
about it the other day saying I really
want to get into rent to rent and
they're like have you done any trick
they wanted to be a bespoke investor
with my source in business yeah and I
were like have you done any training on
it and they said oh no no we're like oh
well where are you based I'm sure that
there's some trainings coming up and I
brought up your website and we'll get
given the link like all the closest ones
in um it's in Leeds and it's next month
uh come to this one because it'll teach
you all the basics about it and they
went oh no it's too far for me I was
like
I I don't want you as one of my
investors exactly because they they'll
fail yeah yeah and you want to be
working with winners how many how many
Academy members have you been doing
business with oh just sold nine my ninth
deal at the minute so
um and about seven of them have been to
Academy members and working through the
academy that in itself pays its money
back yeah exactly and then um there's
two Academy members that I'm having
conversations with one of them actually
I had a meeting with and he literally
went I don't want you to pitch an idea
with me I've got 50 Grand I will give
you 50 Grand as a joint venture if you
pitch the right idea to me yeah it's
like it's the beauty of are you building
a reputation you're building up
relationships with people and trust and
when you're a part of this network
there's almost an extra level of trust
there as well when you're in the academy
people
have faith in you about doing business
with you because if you mess up you're
under an umbrella of authority and
covering whether I will investigate and
put things right yeah rather than just
you know here today gone tomorrow yeah
exactly yeah what is it that drives you
then every day this is again going back
to going back to my past I mentioned
that
um about like my mum and dad and their
beliefs with money and things like that
so my um my dad growing up when I was
growing up my dad had a lot of um issues
with his mental health it was quite
depressed and things like that and and
it was too young to really understand it
at the time but when I look back I can
see
that it was due to his like Financial
illiteracy like he didn't understand
money he didn't understand credit didn't
understand like how to utilize it the
best way so debt was bad everything to
do with debt was bad and
it it drove him to being like a bit of a
dark place where it like it never
physical but it was very like high
emotions and quite like loud and
shouting and screaming at me and my mum
and my brother and things like that
because it wasn't in the best place
mentally and
seeing that growing up and like what
that caused him and the fact that he's
still on like antidepressants till today
because of it
because of money because of finances
because of bad credit because he didn't
understand the way the system works he
could have literally moved all of his
debt onto a zero percent credit card and
been absolutely fine but instead he was
scraping each month to pay the interest
on the day he had and
I
just just seeing that it it's
it's really difficult to
to and to think that there's people in
this world that are still don't have
that
like financial literacy don't understand
money to understand the way that the
system's work don't understand how
they can potentially be in a better
place financially just by managing
things true man I mean they say you know
money doesn't make you happy but I tell
you what also doesn't mean poor yeah you
know being poor certainly makes you
miserable because if you haven't got
enough money if you're living paycheck
to paycheck and you're scraping and you
it's it's uncomfortable yeah I want to
change that just for myself and my
family and for for people it's like for
other people as well so what's driving
me is being able to like my higher
purpose I want to help and Inspire other
people to become financially literate
whether that's through property whether
it's just through better knowledge
around money and things like that I I
really want to just spread that message
and whether that's using social media
platforms or speaking events and things
like that I just want to be able to well
that's the thing man when you reach the
top of the mountain it's best to pull
people up with you yeah exactly because
it can be lonely at the top and that's
one of the reasons why I started the
academy in the first place and it's been
great getting a question people like
yourself and many many many many many
many many many other people so what
would be your best piece of advice then
does someone watching this that wants to
follow in your footsteps that wants to
get into property they've got no money
they want to be doing joint ventures and
Roads events and deal sourcing but
they're starting with no money what will
be your best advice first of all get
your training
um 100 get the training but the second
bit of advice would be you've got so
many experiences in your life up until
this point you've done so many things in
the past like for myself I used to be a
musician I played on stage so that gives
me stage presence and like confidence of
actually speaking to people and things
like that and then I also like you say
around a business I did social media
over on a YouTube channel I've utilized
my skills in marketing to now pull that
into property so you've got so many
experiences in your life whether you've
been in sales whether you've done worked
in a call center whatever you've done
you'll have skills that you can use
within your property Journey that you
need to utilize so people think that
they're going into it completely blank
with nothing it's like no you've got a
lot of skills in your life that you've
had previously and you can pull them in
and like you just put them all into to
the pot and then when you're mixing it
together you just drop property into
there as well and mix it around a little
bit more so true a lot of people work
hard and have skills
but I think if you're going to work hard
anyway you might as well get rich yeah
exactly you might as well use your
skills like people that do sales for
instance I see people you know um who
are selling insurance or they're on the
markets and they're selling fruit and I
think man they've got so much energy in
there they're great at what they do but
it's those same fruit you can just sell
properties yeah there'll be there'll be
a millionaire
is it true I heard that you were very
skeptical about hearing of other
people's success you know I make 20
grand 25 Grand all the winners
Wednesdays now you're one of those guys
talk to me about that I think obviously
when you get to a certain point this is
a bit of a stigma really of that
obviously there's there's levels to this
game and there is people that make like
serious serious money each month but
when when I was sat there in the end of
June on that crash course and then
um you go to the guys at the back that
are all helping out and crewing and
stuff and asking them how much money
volunteers yeah exactly I mean I do that
now and I'm that person so it's like
it's weird being on the other side of
this but go on but it's like so there's
like the guys at the back who are saying
that they're making like five grand ten
Grand 15 grand a month which is like was
just obscene to me at that point and I'm
like
I just don't get it I don't I don't get
how that that's working I don't
understand how that's happening not it's
like it's not that adult I want to
believe it but I don't believe it kind
of thing and like I have faith in myself
that if that is possible I'm gonna get
myself there but I just didn't really
believe it and I think that it's I don't
know I think it's a position of like
putting myself back into that seat and
back into that place and like going to
the crash courses now and seeing these
people sat there it's like I want to
really make it clear that when I say I'm
making around fifteen thousand pounds a
month now
I didn't believe that eight months ago
when I first sat there at that first
crash course before I'd done any
training I didn't believe that that was
possible the people that are thinking
about going to these courses are going
to the crash courses and things like
that it's like
just really I was you I was you eight
months ago and I honestly believe that
if you put your mind to it and you
discipline needs appointments with the
nurse and you thrive in your wind and
you share your wins and things like that
and you live off that kind of vibe and
that high energy that you really can
achieve these kind of things it's not it
you've got the blueprint like with the
train if you come to the trains you've
got the blueprint like I said you've got
that treasure map with the line to the
decks where the Mark's the spot you just
need to be able to actually follow it
yeah and it
I can't thank you and the team and the
guys enough for it really because taking
me from that that mindset where I knew
it was possible but I just couldn't
believe it there was still that kind of
probably my dad's sitting in the back of
my mind kind of thing around the
finances and things like that and money
and living paycheck to paycheck and then
you hear people that are making that
much money it was hard to just get that
switch in that click but
you can do it how does it feel to be on
the other side and now probably have
people watching this YouTube video
thinking in 15 a month yeah [__]
like yeah yeah well that's it
that's the point of what I'm trying to
make is that
um like it's crazy to be on the other
side but I really want people to really
understand that I was in that place not
that long ago and I say I want to be
relatable I want to whenever I make
content or whatever I do things I want
to be relatable I want to be
approachable I want people to feel like
they can they can message me and that
there's not like a a different in levels
like everybody's human everyone's on the
same level I want everyone to solely
family members feel awkward around yeah
yeah you know you're on the outside now
they've got a book an appointment with
your PA now yeah well that's it I mean I
had a friend that I used to work with
and who I was explaining what I do in
property and what I'm what how how like
the things I'm working and stuff and how
I'm creating housing for these people in
in these kind of ways and it went I saw
you just a capitalist prick now then
aren't you all right
like ah I felt like I felt bad that I'd
like
I didn't want to be detaching myself
from anybody
and then I almost I laughed at him at
the same time but I was like like so far
away from the truth of what of what it
actually is but people are gonna have
their opinions and you're never going to
get through to everybody but I just want
to be able to be as relatable as down to
earth as I can with every person that I
talk to every person that I meet and I
want to just inspire people and show
them that look like I was here this was
me this time last year I was going
through something really [__] in my life
going through a crippling anxiety I
didn't really know what I was doing came
to one of your trainings it gave me a
little bit of a vision and a little bit
of a purpose invested in myself for the
long longer term training
sold my old business to really pursue
this new vision that I had and yeah and
it just went went from there really but
it's just it is possible and I can't
reiterate that enough that for the
people watching that it is so possible
just to
like get out of your own way invest in
yourself and do it well mate massively
inspirational and I really appreciate
you taking the time to come out today
and share your story and I can't wait to
continue working with you to absolutely
go from strength to strength and smash
it out of the park respect my brother
thank you appreciate you man thank you
very much
foreign
[Music]